wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
auf sie auf gute gesellschaft und gutes
essen gute gesellschaft ist eine sache
die ich sehr schätze und gutes essen
auch und jetzt habe ich beides können
die tour ist der beruf den sie gelernt
haben warum sind sie jetzt
restaurantbesitzer nun meine eltern
hatten ein kleines bistro in hamburg
mein vater war ein mann der es liebte
später durfte ich dann selber kochen
backen und habe schließlich eine
ausbildung zum konditor gemacht aber
immer die gleichen kuchen zu backen das
war dann nicht mehr genug da aber neben
meinem beruf als konditor auch noch als
restaurantkritiker gearbeitet und bin
durch das ganze land gereist sogar nach
frankreich wissen sie
frankreich ist ein land das ich liebe
sie lieben eine menge
ich denke irgendwann wollte ich dann
nicht mehr kritisieren ich wollte es
besser machen
also habe ich mein erstes restaurant
eröffnet das klingt wirklich band ja ja
das klingt romantisch ices ist zahlen
bitte selbstverständlich lade ich sie
aber keine widerrede gerade sie
natürlich ein
sie ist eine frau die man einladen muss
alles in ordnung mein portemonnaie
ich habe es im hotel vergessen kein
problem ich übernehme das nicht mehr
sehr peinlich ich gebe ihnen das geld
natürlich zurück stimmt danke wann denn
sie haben die wette verloren schon
vergessen
auf videos intakt
[Musik]
danke
ich hoffe sie auf diesem handy anhänge
[Musik]